dony quelqu'un meurt sous votre surveillance vous
n'abandonnez pas qui abandonne jamais nous
sommes pour ne pas assumer la responsabilité de
nos actions
ce document ne fait que déplacer le blâme
désolé Steve que c'est dangereusement
arrogant c'est les Nations Unies dont
nous parlons ce n'est pas  le
Conseil de sécurité mondial ce n'est pas un bouclier ce n'est
pas un saut en hauteur mais c'est dirigé par des gens
avec des agendas et des changements d'agenda c'est
bien c'est pourquoi je suis ici quand j'ai réalisé de
quoi mes armes étaient capables entre de
mauvaises mains je l'ai arrêté arrête de
fabriquer tu as choisi  pour ce faire, si nous
signons ceci, nous abandonnons notre droit de
choisir si ce panneau nous envoie
quelque part, nous ne pensons pas que nous devrions aller et
s'il y a un endroit où nous devons aller
et qu'ils ne nous laissent pas nous ne sommes peut-être pas
parfaits mais le  les mains les plus sûres sont toujours les
nôtres si nous ne le faisons pas maintenant, cela
nous sera fait plus tard